okay
whoa that was like a paintball
[Music]
hello
i'm cole sprouse
and i'm lana condor and welcome to
snacky snacks
we're gonna i'm very excited for this
actually nibble on some snacks today
[Music]
these are the classic goldfish baked
snack cracker cheddar 100 real cheese do
you like goldfish i love goldfish really
let's flavor blast my face do you like
dude okay do you like do you want to
play a game sure and i'm gonna like toss
it up and you're gonna try and catch it
uh you have a lot of faith in how
dexterous i am but i think that you can
do it
one
yeah
now that's a yummy snack it's so good
it's one of my favorite like on-set
snacks standard classic kakarot hard to
beat usually you know exactly what
you're getting
not fish no goldfish
oh so good my turn
in line with the fish
these are calbee shrimp chips love them
i get them at each one all the time
great
i love shrimp chips don't knock it till
you try it i know it can seem a tad
intimidating this yeah but like if it
didn't say shrimp would you care it
looks like a funyun
and it's light you know it's a light
taste of shrimp you must devein your
shrimp there's no veins in this cause
this is just no i like the feces
thank you
okay next one i feel like two meals in
one
these are honey mustard and onion snyder
pretzel pieces i will sometimes put like
a handful of them in my wardrobe pocket
at work
and just like have a little crunch while
i'm waiting for this set up i'm like a
squirrel yeah hard like saving up for
winter yeah but you know what i wish
that there was like i could buy the
seasoning and just put it on everything
look i wanted to that's a bit weird i
wanted to like put it on everything i
gotta with men i'm a huge [ __ ] for honey
mustard just in general yeah honey
mustard anything i will be there
dragging along the floor yeah
i'm like a snail for this [ __ ]
you go for the big boy or you go
for the like little one the little ones
are packed with flavors the little ones
are the most flavorful i know
i go for the big boy because i'm
insecure
um i'm gonna talk to my therapist about
it well
boba one of my all-time favorites
are you getting excited cole's happy he
has his boba
he's coming alive i have very fond
memories of boba growing up because my
brother and i would launch these small
little boba at high speeds at other cars
oh yeah while locked in traffic john and
i were like two mobile turrets just in
the back of our car
awesome do you want to do it nope wait
yes do it
just here ain't no no aim at my hand
okay
whoa
that was like a paintball
that like has a sting that's not as soft
as you would think can i try
meh
yes
what do we got what do we got what do we
got we have the classic cuddle brand
potato chips sea salt and then i'm like
a
like ride or dice sea salt and vin girl
that or barbecue chips but if i can so
just vinegar
yeah because every chip has seasons it
has sea salt so i like to call them
chips i go for like
folded chips what do you mean
oh yeah chips not like just like this
like i'll like search through the bag of
chips no but there's something very very
appealing about like the perfectly
formed
chip
yeah you know what i mean
yeah oh yeah no i know that's a nice one
you're correct on that you're correct on
that like it's texture it's like yeah
yeah no because the other yeah see this
like that's nice like almost a cannoli
or something yeah cheers
all right i think also there's an
element of danger eating a folded chip
like that because you don't know if it's
gonna like
cut your tongue a little bit
your whole lineage is just looking
at how weak our generation has become
straight up wrestling big woolly rhinos
to the ground
ancient humans
this chip is a little sharp i don't want
to cut my tongue tongue
it's true
i'm gonna eat it
delicious good choices so far good
choices so far lana kudos to you thank
you what do we got all right
classic a little melted a little melted
not gonna lie
that's on complex not me
um
i love a klondek bar my brother and i
used to have this ice cream guy in our
neighborhood that would come rooting and
tooting down the alleyway at like 1pm
i would get a klondike bar and my
brother would get a choco taco
which is also made by klondike
and then when we were on the suite life
our crafty uh lady got a ice cream
machine for season two
and they every day they were fresh choco
chocolate and we gained so much weight
in season two
that uh the channel itself was like yo
what's going on
and they kill the ice cream machine
anyhow try it before it melts i've never
had a clown back what oh they're so good
do you want it's a bit more frozen right
now it's a bit melted real good
i'd love if it was but when the ice
cream's got a bit more texture i got
that crunch you know
i'm selectively lactose intolerant
so i'm only going to take one bite
selectively you say
well i'm not trying to give you a
blowout here in the complex thing
all right thank you so good
it's slurpee
[Music]
guys
thank you for joining us
i'm cole sprouse and i've been lana
condor
and this was snacky snack time please
watch our new movie moonshot streaming
on hbo max march 31st
thanks
you